тут у дпс машина просто змінна про
позиція була в заздалегідь штанів цієї особи
так що нікита йому не економічний
стипендії і вона не з'являйся ти бог дасть
на дари мені за 10 сотки
з правди тієї ревеню київ братів
європейських клінік початок річка була
такий студент який вступив на навчання
коли йому гаранта до аркуша прийом його
успішному нам чані гаранта волосся якось
щаблі 825 гривень на повинен бути
підкорений за раз йому умова на вчені
може на ризик зміни води вин вступав
приїжджав скажімо закарпаття дусі іванів
чат і савін рази колона почутті піньйон
намагаюся спілкуємося швидше і тут йому
кажуть готель щаблі це промо ти не
будеш там він замислювався всіх відвідати
ще я хочу ми хочемо проводити реформу ми
не можемо втекти з орального загального
суді більше бути близько 1050 вантаж статтю
нам треба втричі втече і
степан телефон ну не можна його ціни не
можемо ці висівки там і наша пропозиція
була така, що в ряд хоче проводити
реформи пташина охолоне то їх трибур обід
і плавно
надходив і таким чином ми виходимо на тиц
і фрики за 1 травня йому хто студентки
які успішно навчає кожен намагається
чайки
мало за безтурботною травень моли доходи через
парних який переріс вин гаранта вона
буде мат і щаблем і тебе доля буду
сумарно башта 59 сотки ось почав ми
тут. зараз за 1
зрозуміло знаходилася одна петрушки нами
поля трушці пак і автономії адже паве
дальності університету
подавитися тут я міждж можна містечку
що можна показати і розміри стипендій
ось придушити і все-таки відьміни
на одному of applied ці 20 адже сотки
можна буде і відьомі камені одному
петара 500к було три мати з фізики три
п'ятірки за семестр сама дружини чоловікові його
тимохін її можна це я cavid
соток webmin якимось і за раз виходу море
хто на вітрилах вул здається губи до 500
комп'ютера від 500 багаття цю розписку
радники можна змішувати і можна знову
t5 адже сотки в тозі безаких будуть мати
первинним щаблем ми за меншою особою
так вухо плані меншими ступенями
я б подумував все-таки з залисини на
зростання студентського самої радість і в
чайних раціон і що нові лягнути
дроти гри для в чани ірода для
студентського самоврядування такі
панова одруженим вузли висить йому люблять і
фарбую почати для студентки
ну ми можна писати і 40500 означає що
ми зможемо to die всіх моїх почуттів та по
генофонду об'єктивно подагра зозуль
щоб звести баланс
виходив з товщі вигляд мінки буде це
равіц сік це означає це три студенти
на три види мініки на 200 штук ці всі
мало ми можемо написати знову можна
написати і висимо стриму вати самі
відьмі якимось самим ти хто найкраща
минулих прошу
з досягли за 1 до 7
але відтінку а то вид у вас вид 90 до 191
дасть обидва своя града частіше буде
шо я сьогодні ми можемо гори ти про
абсолютні розміри степу генофонду
орендована 3,4 мільярда як мінімум так
можемо про цілий поверх а йдучи по vnc
системою мінус вигляд і ми можемо габарити
пра правило рус у справі
нами зрозумів про справедливі де
міністерству виділяла на шкіру ВНЗ
про пост питні опції про партійні та
кікасі студенті кіно спілкуються забігти у
кішки так не а я крим
i'm on the lies to get потрібно писати
формули
я килима ховають та я кислий a local та так
я розумієш його не щось шевченка і
є шанс від ріму. 25
montale 4 механізми малий і не зарубали
зарубали такі конкурентні способи
розпаді удар за блискавку коли абітурієнт у
вирішив де будаєві місця і ви пом'яті і
такі проблеми у херсоні кіно берліном
нас пропливали у його рича просто стоять і
у залі лімфології вистояв ви стали б
здогадатися і конкурентний принцип
проти ти що я кисть поправочка можна
рубати і на великому, а захоче їх tomoya
кращим у студента
за
жало
визнати лише це ступінь я затримав
троянда має мої
знає про ваші пропозиції абсолютно не
суперечити і
та 53 статті конституції
держава може за карбованець може
про що у неї сланова сидячи на табір
а можемо і так і запишемо, що право нас ти
піднімаєш сили за лижний віджет
фінансово не осяє він спалах царі вниз
formulas
а тепер дівчина за руку на спецфонді ви
стрима це всю матеріальну базу свою
рахунок їх не гарної із луганська
самоуправління фінансується за рахунок
контрактники дзвону чудово
то доброго однакові пустим дарує в але
списку
funk тепер шумом польщу маршрут саппорт
ширше яйця на всіх хто навчається на
належний форм фінансово вдень
про тримаючи мені комунального міста
так ну давайте прикривати перервати не так
які малим вже ми зітремо його ти поставили
за молоді не я важу даних доводиться
покажу швидше сказати про vanish її
реалізація минулих та смужка
чому не природна назва
проекти цих рада обговорити якісь
можливо тому що наприклад зараз
відбувається aeterna
а і
одним лідера цього не пікірувати
після сьогоднішнього огляду дня ми ж
дородові motex за трояндами ти правильним
минька або йому себе показувати готувати
Які шляхи не було декі спекуляціями за
розпадом дискусії 5 особа та дорада intex
виставляємо на граматиці обороні том
числа і студентки організації
поправки всі всій зоні були якими 7
закону
нам потрібно кейко днишев вёдер давати
висунутої та й кіба
ось цифра була на базі старого це -
заради то чисто технічна
робота за 1 проти ситуацію до тіла
причиною будди храм пекельний аборт був мій
до кінця ти дня будуть граматика місті
msi - ми в сексі та ми виставляємо на
бугор і на практиці ми вже всередині нього
відразу тому відразу мид і праведно ми
просто і кисть по малкін не зможу
волосся
тип паперу висунуть і виставляємо
граматика місто в нашій 1 харчування
так Так Так
месі
ось я хотів, у вас просто ідеально
комісії б я вчора сам сивина cent
документів за може бути поверх своєї
ісида і туди носу відпалив валіда отже я
порядок з відвареним кабміном вниз
армія степ єдиний фонд дали pci нарада
затвор джея правило
нарощування виплати стипендій eurohoff
двп славиться формула рейтингу
зведіть порядок формування рейтингу до
листи підроблена комісія роз'їдаючи
екрані все харчування в тому числі і ви
потім це реально доповниться еньші степу
гейна комісія за ціни правилам складу я
список студентів на 3 манія стипендії та
я вже він і порушено правило не порушено
порядок по ректор висуваючись
так буде правильно опчана рада може
прийняти правила лише за положенням
зораном студентського самоврядування to
toe за розсікає і звичайно харчування
стипендіальної комісії такому вийшли
дивана потрібно тут
нічого нового по 3 вантажі і може
замахнулися
немає ціни ви краще виходять харчування
, автономії до Індії проекту порядку c
завищуємо
ми біля порядку ланцюга завищуємо маяки чоловіки
весь виплати матеріальної доплати
поїздки по телефону так що мені що
ер азарів ступеня можна я думаю
що це базовий шоти і тут інша
нам треба там
на
тут
але в нас
минулі
та постанові
не
так не рамки
шановні
і
давайте скажемо так от зараза записано
загальна формула
мета бал для формування рейд на 90
сотки розпадається з успішності девід
сотки менше показ не кіно у кого менше
діаліз треп змінити з перед нашими
у нас або
не так він абсолютно святий вдома сказали
механізм прибираємо критеріальні
показані
тому що в Європу в болонському процесі
критеріального tinka
і бесіді bessini викор 100 боїться повз
цього я
зайняли
я
Ну як
аж і музика
і листів висипати
і не крутить і зараз я йду Володимир
Антальє що скаже приклад
треки варилася михайлівна на
гуманітарних факультетах та 7090 криму та
стипендію а мехмат моя 43 високі так по
математики вниз у нас шевченка споживаючи
у топ-50 святого їхніх університетів
рейтингу
а за голом гвинтики в 600 так кому
оплати ти ти хто піднімаючи світ стати і
тим хто дасть на середньому або
значить пан андрей акцій список за
спосіб ironik спеціально стоїте
спеціалізації заїкін первинні стипендія
буду і ціна на такий принцип якшаться
потрібні для держави спеціальність
таких у 4 йде дуже низький
прохідний бал за але проступи куди
знайдуть кваліфіковані штабники
зробили математики та фізики з добре
ну
debut оксана білківський батор народів
приклад
1 при фіксованому удар за блискавки при
фіксованому на спеціальність 4 фізики
прийшов dance туди і всього на все
означає черецький коротким там просто не
буду кому ви куди
ну хто знає так миша паралельно руб
миша зарплату вчителю піднімаючи сміттєвий
адінкра
випусти
докладно
кого буде лише
драма
правильно ліцей вид соток
проте війна шкірою спеціальності на
кожному курсі це буде справедливо
ще одне харчування за 1 1 курс ось три
моїх стипендії
все так все я що за право чого ти тут
ідеї рейтинг пробуду вати за результатом
і сина з тросом з true
ваша пропустіть скидами першому
семестрі
по шуму самі країни виплачувати крем
суті вони звучали
не давайте давайте ось резона пропустити
лагер і все-таки за результатами синів
щоб буду війна так рейдену
списаний за результатом з іншого
cc завищуємо porsche porsche есемес
результатом і наново
смужка
не
на і просиш а formulation середній бал
за сесію
вона не знає може писати свої формули
наприклад їх що її профіль не
дисципліни і візуально вас вивчаючи
призначення си їх не ори зона для
підготовки ми щось можемо стає
свої права ми пропадаємо він так але і
пральня формула з середній бал за
сесію і що там будуть диференціювання
задника можна їх раковини євро холод і
а потім заїкою схемою порушувалося туди
таке бали за науку граматика вище
дерев можна на холод і звичайно теж
не жартувати успішність 120
підсмажиться будь ласка 9010 а пропорція
дістати не дуже треп змінює намаза
парочки пакет на романські оборони ви
носа доброго
не
випадково за спорт та сподівалися
для ми статики і займись науки буду
творчий одяг я що в молоді співак вже
виступаю у спектаклях чиї концерти для
чому йому на нарах а ось
минулих
я думаю що cessna вже харчування та у вас
закрито арени і взагалі нарада поважаю рани
студентського самарі даного поля гаї
але давайте не оголює автономію ми і
так не не між мого обличчя від 90
сотки віце успішності
ви дошка
конфлікти бувають завжди міни я я адже
побачити на ваші харчування ми не можемо в
нормативно-правових актах прахова ти
всім url або конфліктів та конфлікти
готової з відпочинку і ви вирішити конфлікт і
ми можемо на всі випадки життя посад і
норми так давай утворити
на ми можемо тег іпотеку і ти мінфіну за
те що наш чує
nec
владимир анатолійович ми закінчили
законопроект за раз його від внутрішнього
задня прой-де-те реформа фінансування
овочі та квіти форми апельсин
я стала не просто дружиною
навіть банку рубенівна
не так не так все просто ми хочемо і
заголовком мінфін точно спить 3 мою тему
висновки ти
штанів
статусне прибутку ви хронізації за
забезпеченням усіх подарунків їх пиляння та
фінансовий апарат
на
не завжди
правильно
алли одна маленька близький особисто слова
одна маленька репліка
запаху по них вищого світла і ми на 12
разом з вікі і души а за я пензлем вас
види
нічого за я пензлем а за я пензлем по
диких спеціальностях демон точно з
філософської дискусії вона напевно і ви
всіх заруба
його складно був тоді
я читав 500